[Musique]
oui eh bien tu vois les traditions la
chandeleur en provence sont aussi
nombreuses que variées et d'ailleurs
elle change avec disons les villages les
villes et les régions
il inquiète tout de même quelques unes
que nous devons observer plus
particulièrement règle générale c'est
par exemple à la chandeleur que l'on ait
fait la crèche et là ça donne lieu à
certaines scènes un peu dangereuse pour
les santons mais qui réjouissent
toujours les santoni il ya aussi les
cérémonies plus particulièrement à
marseille de la vierge noire que l'on
sort de la crypte de l'église
saint-victor et que l'on honore en
faisant brûler des cierges de cire
offerte
pourquoi verte c'est toute une histoire
que nous avons pas le temps de raconter
il y à aussi évidemment la tradition des
crêpes qui se fait dans toute la france
des crêpes que l'on fait sauter en
mettant un louis d'or dans la main à
l'heure actuelle au prix de l'orge doute
que cette tradition soit encore
respectée très souvent néanmoins les
crêpes ce fonds il ya enfin puis
particulièrement marseille à l'heure la
fameuse conditions des navettes et là
c'est une véritable ruée
après la procession à saint-victor
procession qui a lieu à 6 heures du
matin ce qui fait que la plupart du
temps les cinéastes n'y sont pas c'est
une véritable ruée vers le four des
navettes qui est très ancien et qui a
tenu encore actuellement par un homme
qui respecte la tradition rue nicolo
dire c'est le grand jour pour vous
aujourd'hui
vous vendez combien de navettes dans la
journée vous savez c'est difficile à
dire mais on peut dire les dizaines de
milliers aujourd'hui vous avez vu vous
même le bond qui avait devant la porte
et vous savez ça va très vite
est-ce que les gens qui viennent acheter
des navettes sont son vrai nom des
marseillais ce qu'ils reviennent chaque
année
ah oui ça nous avons notre clientèle
habituelle bien sûr et puis alors nous
avons les nouveaux alors les nouveaux
100 rencontres suite il disait je
voudrais une navette devrait de navettes
alors ça nous fait sourire parce qu'à
côté quelqu'un demande 3,12 elle ou 4
douzaine de navettes
il y en a même une d'une dame tout à
l'heure qui m'a téléphoné en me disant
est ce que vous pouvez me préparer une
douzaine de navettes pour ce soir je
répondu bien sûr madame on va la
préparer
lorsque vous pourriez nous donner la
recette de ces fameuses navette car vous
êtes le seul à faire
la véritable authentique navette de
lachamp donnait à écouter vous savez je
suis très brave je vous donnerai tout ce
que vous voudrez mais pas la recette des
navettes
[Musique]